so welcome all
um uh Sebastian are excited to work
together
um on this and have very different
background so I'll introduce myself and
Sebastian but it's it's an example of
um we hope to sort of bring you behind
the scenes I think that's one thing
Sebastian I've talked about is we've
we're collaborating he was here you know
he's now back in Sweden but he was here
at the beginning of this year we met
each other we have interesting
um convergence in our two very different
backgrounds in terms of the questions
we're asking about
um uh using chat gbt
um my background is I work in the design
school at Stanford the D School teaching
students
um the creative tools to routinely
innovate design thinking design process
ideation prototyping empathizing all the
different sort of techniques we use in
particular
um we'll be talking about a a class that
I've done for a long time here running
the accelerator called Launchpad for the
engineering school with Sebastian and I
are going to talk about some of the
things we've been doing to work with
those students teams to launch
businesses using some of these
techniques and some of the questions we
have mutually but a good example of
someone who's a teaching faculty working
with somebody with a researcher so I
spend a lot of time in classes a lot of
time with students designing classes and
I'll let Sebastian introduce himself and
his unique background
yeah great thanks Perry
um yeah so I'm I'm really excited uh for
this session
um as as uh Harry said it's gonna be
interactive and we're gonna
um yeah share some of our experiences so
my name is Sebastian kakowski
um yeah coming live to you from
Stockholm Sweden uh where I'm an
assistant professor at the Stockholm
School of Economics at the house of
innovation so a lot of focus on digital
Technology Innovation how it's used and
decision making and strategy I'm also as
Perry mentioned I I visited Stanford
last last semester a fall semester
um where I met
met Perry and was fortunate enough to
you know start working together uh with
you
um and I'm also a digital fellow um at
the Stanford digital economy lab where
um I'm involved in some similar research
looking at how we interact with
algorithms how how we kind of
collaborate with them to to make better
decisions come up with better strategies
and I'm also an affiliate affiliated
researcher here at the institute for
future studies looking at how AI
proliferates in society so it's a topic
that's very very um dear to me uh really
excited to be here today to to talk more
about it yeah um and um let's learn
about them for a minute I'm going to
push this poll to the audience
um let me know if you see it but we're
just going to spend 30 seconds if you
just click and tell it's a way that we
can sort of hear about you
um and sort of tailor this interactive
media we've got all these dashboards and
all this stuff up we are real people
we're not Bots um and we're going to
react real time to that input so
um as many of you as you who can you
should have a poll up on your screen
which at least to my screen says live
um just go ahead and click on there
we'll spend maybe just 10 more seconds
and if you don't feel like doing it
don't do it but it's a way of
interacting and we can tailor a bit of
um oh did I push the results slide okay
here we go pushed audience there we go
all right there's the poll yeah see
that's the test I'm a real person
um anyway with that we'll do just maybe
15 seconds and let you jot some stuff in
and then Sebastian just flip back and
share your screen and we'll use those
results later in the talk
but welcome all we're really interested
to dig into this topic with you and I
think you'll learn a lot about
um the questions that both Sebastian and
I were asking from different fields and
brought us together to do some um
interesting experiments which we pre
maybe a precursors have asked you should
be honest we're still baffled by some of
the results yeah if you can help us
anyway with that Mr Bastion go ahead and
um if you just grab the screen back
that'd be great
yeah
um right
um so yeah I uh I I want to just mention
also that we didn't plan on starting to
work together uh you know I apparently
we kind of met serendipitously and found
out that we have these Mutual interests
and and overlap but from coming from
different perspectives
um so this kind of resulted in our
efforts our explorations of of this
topic so as you can see here the
objectives for the webinar today is
first of all to really kind of have a
conversation about the significance of
AI and and what it means for Creative
professions for tasks
um not just jobs in general there's also
a lot of talk about you know impact on
jobs but I really like to have a more
kind of nuanced discussion about various
tasks and how we can actually augment
our capabilities right then automate us
entirely and so I think that's kind of a
topic that we're going to have today a a
thread throughout the webinar and we're
going to try at least to make AI
generative AI a little more approachable
and hopefully Inspire some relevant use
cases to make your lives a little easier
every day
so it's not as as scary as it can seems
so here's the agenda first uh we're
going to start with a little
introduction uh just a very light touch
uh kind of uh talk uh an overview of the
Technologies uh generative AI large
language models getting to some real
world examples that are hopefully a
little more relatable than a lot of the
hype that's going on then we're gonna
break for a mid webinar q a and do a
little live demo so we'll see what
happens there and then we're gonna talk
a little bit about something that's
referred to as prompt engineering you
might have heard of it it basically
relates to how you ask
these chat Bots questions so that they
can better help you accomplish what you
are working on at the moment to make
them better work for you and help you
and then again we want to hear even more
from you about your experiences what are
your questions uh fears uh Ambitions
aspirations uh so as I said you know
really looking forward to to making this
Interactive
so let's see here right so so let's
start with the with an overview
um what are we talking about here uh
because it's really it can seem like a
daunting topic but no that's basically
what we're talking about is constructing
you know intelligent agents algorithms
so going back uh historically in the 50s
uh you might say that the talk the field
of AI uh
um kind of came into existence in the
modern sense with logical systems
rule-based system you may be familiar
with them if then logic so but after a
while researchers realize that you know
this is it's pretty hard to kind of
write rules for everything we're going
to do in life so after a while with a
more sophisticated techniques more data
we kind of started adopting as a society
data driven approaches so using large
amounts of data to make predictions and
kind of coming up with useful algorithms
that way and today the New Frontier that
you know just about everyone is talking
about is generative AI which can be seen
as you know contrasting these the the
first wave was kind of logical wool
driven the second one was more
predictive inductive data-driven what
we're seeing today is generative so in a
sense it's very creative it can help us
come up with new topics new ideas and
that's really what we want to talk about
today you know kind of a more balanced a
little more optimistic uh constructive
view of how we can use these
Technologies to be creative and
innovative
um so how are these tools today develop
so they're not manually coded they're
not rules that we specify everything we
want them to do in every conceivable
context like symbolic AI the good
old-fashioned AI it's also not
exactly the same thing as machine
learning uh it's it uses machine
learning but it's it's been trained on
vast amounts of language so for now
let's stick with large language models
for example gpt3 here you see the data
set that it's been trained on so common
crawl basically internet the internet uh
and Reddit you see there 22 60 common
crawl and then digitized uh books uh to
data sets there eight percent each and
lastly Wikipedia uh three percent so
they're right to the next to the right
next to the pie chart you see a typical
neural network where it's kind of
modeled after our how our brains work so
various Connections in the brain are
re-weighted uh so that it can calibrates
the predictions and that enables these
systems to kind of predict the next word
when they answer your prompt basically
what these models are doing is
predicting the next most likely word in
the sequence of of outputs that
generally tend to make sense and then
these are further kind of trained
adjusted fine-tuned from manual human
feedback so people who basically give it
a thumbs up or a thumbs down if if they
like the answer so this is called
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback RL HF and this four models chat
Bots like gpt3 this makes them even more
useful for us in everyday tasks
um so that's in a nutshell how how large
language models are are developed and
how we access them well it's with a
range of tools many of them you've
you've probably heard of so I
in in my opinion I think the most
accessible useful ones that perform well
are on the far left there it's um open
ai's chat GPT
um specifically GPT 3.5 or 4 but also
Bing uh AI which you could say is very
similar to gpt4 but they're also open
open source Alternatives
like open assistant or stable vikunya or
a stability AI has different models that
perform fairly well
um but there are also some limitations
that we want to point out it's it's
worth keeping in mind uh because there's
a lot of heated debates around the uh
you know the the threats and the
limitations uh you know in relation to
these models
um and uh they acknowledge you know open
AI for example on their home page you
know when you enter and start using
Chachi Piti it tells you about some of
the limitations but there's a range of
them so they've been known to what is
called uh hallucinate so they are
basically as I was saying they're
predicting the next Sebastian sorry
interrupt we're getting a couple of
messages about
um what people are seeing are people uh
Robin or Amy do you want to give us a
heads up are are we projecting the the
images out from the deck correctly
okay
so
um folks chatting you'll get maybe a
comment from somebody on the team to
help you with that yeah go ahead
Sebastian it's already yeah great thanks
Barry
um yeah as they're saying it's it's live
interactive so who knows what will
happen uh but yeah coming back to the
limitations it's just worth keeping in
mind
um that they do hallucinate they sound
very uh the models I should say can
sound very convincing uh they want to
please you they want to come up with
answers to your questions but it's
really a range a set of predictions of
the most likely tokens parts of words
that it provides you with the response
to your prompts there's also privacy
concerns uh so I would be careful to
share too sensitive data uh with the
models because that's uh later on it
might be surface I'll show how that
looks like you can actually turn off the
chat history in chat GPT but still live
would be a little careful in terms of
what I uh share with these models when
using them there's also copy right
concerns as I was just saying these
models are trained on for example Reddit
or other forums or Internet or Wikipedia
they don't pay to use this data it could
include your data if it's accessible on
the internet so there are issues there
what happens if these models produce
output that is very similar to artists
digital work for example digital art
that they've been trained on and also
there's the issue of mass information
what happens when
basically large parts of the uh of the
world of the world's population
including Bad actors get access to these
tools where they can kind of craft very
convincing compelling no misinformation
uh posts images things like that so it's
definitely worth keeping in mind
okay so I I hope you're all with me so
far
um because with that
um it's not going to get much more
technical than that it's gonna get much
more practical uh from now on
um so moving on to the topic using
creative work uh what can this look like
what are some some domains some use
cases
um as we mentioned before we'd like to
talk more about augmentation rather than
automation so yeah I'd add a Sebastian
here that there's a lot of questions
coming up about
um you know how does this apply to a
particular domain area how does it apply
to buyout we have a biologist we have uh
people doing data analysis we all all
kinds of people are asking about their
particular job like what will happen for
this or what will happen with
um you know governments or what will
happen with you know these particular
use cases the this is the the what we
have found really interesting is this
topic and it's it's sort of um maybe
think about your own feel world and we'd
be curious to see how this sort of line
of inquiry that that Sebastian I share
and we're going to share how we're
working on it what the implications are
and I think you'll see it sort of um
viable to all of these fields we hope um
it's just a way of thinking about what
the tools are we're fascinated with what
um we feel they are very very good at or
potentially very good at and fascinated
with this interaction human beings are
having
um with this goal so if that makes sense
this is sort of the topic take this
topic and apply it to your domain area
and maybe that helps you generate a
question about this in the in the Q a
that's that's wonderful because yeah
again
um I I I really want to emphasize also I
want to hear we want to hear from you
what are your what resonates with you
what seems most relevant to you but
um again what I'm hoping for what we're
hoping for it is to illustrate the
augmentation use cases uh the
opportunities for you to to use these to
leverage these very powerful
Technologies uh to to make your work
make your life a little easier perhaps
even more fun
um so one use case here content creation
ideation I was talking to one company
for example uh that realized they didn't
need uh to spend as much time on their
newsletter uh because they could
leverage uh Chachi PT to write better
News letters that uh more people click
on
um and faster at that so it's it's just
a little example of of some of the
potential here in so it can this can
also relate to blog posts coming up with
prototypes ideas uh marketing campaigns
so it's really to get a head start in in
your thinking you know when you're
looking at that blank page I don't know
where to start this is an excellent use
case in general I I would say
um and yeah so the examples there and
most of the images by the way uh have
been generated with um uh no image
generators uh like Dolly to mid-journey
uh being image Creator uh you'll see
that there are some various Styles
coming up here I but um it's it's really
easy and fun to get started using
experimenting with these tools so
product development Innovation this is a
little closer to what we'll talk about
and you'll share very in just a couple
of minutes but yeah using it to come up
with ideas Concepts uh as a as a
sounding word uh basically
um again as I was just saying I myself
have been playing around a lot with the
image generators as well so concept
generation
visualizing you know different concepts
ideas and new ways that maybe you
wouldn't have thought of or at least
getting options alternatives to consider
again something we'll come back to in
just a couple of minutes yeah and this
is then we'll dig into it I think this
idea of working with Sebastian we've
been talking a lot about it as not
another way to say this this title to
this slide is thinking about it as an
option engine not an answer engine and I
think that might help sort of frame a
bit of
um how you might be thinking about
um if I have questions in my work if
there's areas of inquiry
Um this can be we've we've been
experimenting and uh Sebastian's going
to go into a fascinating study he did so
there's studies and then we're just
we're we're experimenting in our classes
and and trying different things to get
that behavior into the human beings how
might they use this to help them
generate a lot of options in a in an
area of inquiry and maybe even increase
the range of options I think research is
a great example of where that might be
really valuable and a couple people ask
about this how does this affect if I'm a
researcher
yeah yeah obviously it's super relevant
to to us uh to me uh so there are some
tools that are a little more geared
towards uh you know including sources
references being a little more
transparent so here are some examples of
those so specifically for the images
here they use the stable diffusion uh
the Excel model which personally that's
my favorite but no again Tinker find uh
the tools that that you find useful and
intuitive
um but there are a couple of different
options for researchers uh if you want
to try illicit consensus perplexity
those are a little more transparent but
still it's it's early days there some of
them are beta in beta stages still and
finally a use case that's maybe not
talked about as much as the others but
is is how no many people think that
there's a lot of potential in using
Vector databases so basically instead of
using you know having to use keywords
you can actually connect your knowledge
base your various data sources in a
company or you personally and they can
be vectorized no in they can be
represented in what's called Vector
embeddings so they become vectors
basically and you can search in natural
language and find and combine knowledge
sources in your organization or in your
own personal files making it much more
intuitive in the sense of you know
talking to a chatbot to use your own
data and think of you know what did I
write in that last email I sent Perry
can you bring me up to speed and then it
would help me
send something sensible in response to
parity when we email next
um great so yes this is uh this is
exciting I love this this is the most
recent study uh uh coming out no a study
um I did um together with uh colleagues
and uh in Switzerland and and Copenhagen
um it's it's kind of an a topic where
brother I should say a context I didn't
expect to wind up in uh chess but it's
actually a context that has been
profoundly transformed by digital uh
digital tools and the use of data and
algorithms uh so you may remember or be
familiar with the story of how Garrick
is part of the best chess player in the
world last two IBM's deep blue chess
computer and since then basically many
including Casper have said if you can't
beat them then join them so they
um kind of set up these alternative
tournaments when you actually develop
tweak use your own algorithm that is
kind of your co-pilot and tells you
these are the moves you consider you
should consider you should use a rook
you know to D5 or something like that or
you should adopt this strategy so it
becomes a teammate basically
um so here it's again the um the Centaur
logic so it's something that amplifies
your performance it helps you perform
better
and they also had some tournaments where
they automated their moves
um entirely
but so what I what we look at in these
um games is what happens to a
competition what happens to the moves
they make so we analyzed a couple of
million moves and found some really
interesting results uh in short we found
that the old kind of skills of playing
chess
no longer determine who wins instead
it's who can leverage the computer the
algorithms best so just anecdotally uh
in the first very first of these
tournaments in my data set we have some
Grand Masters some world champions in in
chess and they lose to these amateurs at
these amateur uh you know chess players
so the winners were two amateur U.S
chess players who were experts at data
and leveraging algorithms here's a quote
from a U.S Grandmaster who I also had in
my data sets he says when he was trying
getting into what's called Centaur chess
or freestyle chess he said I use my
brain it's better than the chess
algorithm uh in this case Ripka on six
out of seven days of the week but
um he lost and most others lost who were
not able to leverage data and leverage
algorithms to to compete and what I see
in my turn in in my data also is that
they kind of stop participating in these
tournaments over time and go back to
playing ordinary chess I think that's a
really interesting analogy if we think
about Society in general right
in this study is I think so fascinating
Sebastian because it it's at the heart
of this what what sort of propelled our
work and the things we're going to show
about some some just some we do all
kinds of things all the times that
you're getting things in terms of
um uh professors but I remember vividly
this was something I met you you had me
read a few things we met again and this
was something we had a long conversation
about is this idea of
the players that were able to
incorporate the technology the AI as a
useful tool a place to inquire a place
to try something who used it multiple
times
um were more successful in this in this
confined experiment of you know a chess
tournament and I thought there's a there
was an interesting question here that I
think's worth uh pausing on because I
think it's it's a different way of
stating what we're what we're going to
get into in a minute
um Vera uh I don't wanna the love
who posted some cognitive Scholars have
stated that these tools are merely
Scholastic parrots and cannot be
creative what is your stance on this
um the
we want to be clear what we're what
we're going into here and um in terms of
using these tools and creativity is
using these tools to augment your
creative process AI is not able to be
curious It's not able to be surprised
it's not able to infer meaning
um there's there's so many things we're
at such early stage but it is
relentlessly able to generate material
and evaluate material ins if you direct
it right and this is a good example of
this and I think Barry your question was
really great because I think no we're
not talking about in any way shape or
form
um in any of these things teaching any
students this is this is a good thing to
replace remember we're thinking
augmentation not answer
and we we've seen this happen with
students they'll they'll use
um chat gbt or somebody mentioned even
Auto GPT to get an answer and they're
underwhelmed you know it's not it's not
as creative as I could be and we'll talk
about an interstitial step
um which is in creative process
what we know is good creative output is
correlated with lots of volume
generating lots of material
that's where we've seen some particular
use cases that are um interesting and
Sebastian's research gets at the heart
of this is if you think about the next
move in a chess game being a somewhat of
a creative process having those elements
players that were able to use this this
computer to help them generate more
optionality
um gained a better perspective and and
we're able to
um succeed in that task with uh with
um better better options but what the
computer was doing was not deciding the
move it was helping them
um just look at more options
yeah I I think that's really well put
also
yeah and and that's something where you
know I'm learning a lot from from you
Perry you know thinking about creativity
and uh uh you know thinking about design
in these terms of you know what is it
what is the problem we're solving in but
then how can a a machine help us solve
that so taking over the grunt work the
number crunching generating lots of
options for us to to choose from I think
that's one of the most in more practical
terms that's one of the most uh common
uh mistakes I see people make when they
try to use generative AIS like they use
it as a as Google let's say or Wikipedia
but that's not it's not a search engine
in that sense
what is it not good at and I think some
of those some of those things that are
so critical for Creative work are going
to be and Sebastian would know more
about this or my understanding is so far
like they're they're really hard to be
curious
um you know to infer and be surprised
and be able to notice something because
it's Unique and different those are
things that are still uniquely to the
domain of human I mean I've read a
couple of books one was um the alignment
problem uh by Brian Christian which I'd
recommend maybe put it in the notes but
a terrific book about the the things
that were sort of that these computer
models are are potentially good at and
that and what is uniquely human in terms
of our psychology so thanks now but
that's that's sort of one area in the in
the domain of creativity I know those
things are
um a place we've seen this ability to
sort of bring in some of these tools but
you need a you you're still driving your
creative process with these unique
abilities to to notice things be
surprised be curious to ask the right
question that chat GPT is not going to
be able to ask the right question
and that's that's true for many cases or
many contexts that are digitally
transformed that you move up kind of the
task is you kind of deploy a system
let's say your algorithms to solve a
problem but you still have to understand
the problem you're solving or the
problem you're solving for a customer a
client a stakeholder so it's more about
kind of in the context of Chess you're
not kind of operationally
selecting you know coming up with all
the alternatives for where the pieces go
but you still think about the overall
strategy uh so so that's a useful way of
thinking about having to you know
upskill and and reskill uh yourself
thank you
right I I think obviously you uh Harry
you think we're great going into the
augmentation yeah so
um so this was uh so
we are there's a difference so one thing
I want to be clear about is
um we might use language
um we want to use it appropriately in
this is Sebastian does these research
papers
um those are studies that are set up
with controls and variables and then
um what we do a lot in our classes is
we're teaching classes
um we've been collaborating with another
collaborator we'll mention who is
involved with one of these that teaches
a class in
um in Australia so we get a chance to
run the same thing in a different class
you know a few months from now as their
term starts and so we're we're mixing it
up and we I I happen to be doing
um a class uh right now called Launchpad
uh you can Google it so is it
launchpad.stanford.edu which is an
accelerator here in the engineering
school and we have passionate Founders
launching businesses using
um creative process to do it so it's
different about this accelerator at
Stanford is we use experimentation to
launch the business so in a way a launch
to learn so they're constantly building
launching things putting them out there
no business plans allowed just launching
to learn so a really creative group and
we're very open with them and introduce
Sebastian to them and we we've um we've
done a broad tools transparently into
them that we're we're experimenting with
where they fit
um in the creative work these Founders
are doing so think about they're
relentlessly trying to you know brand
their offer they're trying to
um you know get the right feature set
they're they're trying to build out a
website you know with copies so all
that's happening and here's some
experiments so we're going to show them
to you and what's what I'm smirking
about is we like we're we're baffled by
some of the results uh because they're
they're unexpected
um and they're not these are not
research experiments these were just um
transparent with students that were
fascinating this you know we're going to
try using um Chachi PD to use a
particular in one to create options in
one of one of the classes we tried that
we
had it when nether aspect of
creativities you generate a lot of
material how do you edit down we used it
to edit alongside the students and see
what results that yielded and then we
had it use it we used it to notice
patterns in materials so when we we
would generate we'll talk about this
they generated and actually there were
some questions about how to use it in
areas like this we also used it to
notice patterns um and and AI is
particularly good at that and we use it
in that case we're just going to talk
about these
um and then we'll dive in and from the
poll results you know there's there were
um
uh only a small fraction of you haven't
been on these tools which is awesome so
there's only about 20 that haven't
experienced these tools so it's awesome
and I can tell by the questions people
are dipping their toes in and and have
loads and loads of questions so my hope
is this opens up this topic for all of
you about what it means to use it as an
augmentation tool so with that let's go
into cross domain prompting
um this was something we did so imagine
now
um the
um the students are
um in a class this is a picture of the
classroom we've pixelated things as well
as we can and the idea was
um this idea of cross-domain prompting
I'll try to explain it really really
succinctly
um humans in generating ideas so think
about we're trying to generate an idea
so I'll use it as an example one of the
students has a really interesting
somebody who's been interacting a lot
with us
um here's a really interesting idea for
a real estate startup given there's a
big challenge in commercial real estate
in a lot of cities he wants to sort of
in a way reinvent we work by by doing
micro leases between people that are
stuck with office spaces now with hybrid
work that are that still want to have
live meetings and how do they do live
meetings and could they share office
space with other companies and how do
they figure out what things on their
calendar are particularly good for in
person
what things are better for hybrid so
it's it's a really fascinating startup
idea
um and one of the things he was trying
to figure out was you know what is the
potential business model for this like
you know how am I going to do all these
bookings and match people you know
together and and figure that out cross
domain prompting the concept is in
somebody's at there's a few questions
asked about you know for example
um I can't remember who it was uh maybe
Bonnie or Linda I can't remember was in
the in the questions here but somebody
asked about if I put a question into
chat gbt does that become part of what
you know the the
um the computer and the database takes
on and then uses the answer is yes and
we use that aspect to use cross domain
prompting so in this case the student
and we sort of pixelated this because we
wanted to just you know keep things
private but in this case I'll just
describe high level so this student put
in to chat gbt I'm I have a startup this
startup is doing this sort of pairing of
people who have a lease that's that's
got a lot of time available on it and
other people that are working hybrid and
I want to try to put people together in
a in an interesting way you know if it's
efficient
and what he then thought of so creative
creatively he thought of an analog and
this is something we do this is an
example we did this with students where
they did it just by themselves with
using an analog and then we use the
computer to do it
um and they sort of compared the results
generated but what you do then is you
say okay the the chat gbt gets the
context you say given this startup idea
now my question is could you apply the
business model of eBay to this eBay is
an auction house it puts together buyers
and sellers all the time could you apply
their business model to my startup just
in a way just Clash that with it
um and then the you know chat CBD
generates a bunch of ideas it says here
are the principles of eBay's business
plan you know if they were applied to
this startup these would be
considerations okay and in some cases
you get really you know sort of
um uh fascinating bizarre results like
you should have a rating system and and
you should have people do reviews and
you know you should have variable
pricing and was I remember the moment we
did this it was actually
um one of the things the founder the
student had not thought of is this idea
of variable pricing he thought huh I had
a fixed pricing schedule but I never
thought of variable pricing like you
know eBay is dynamic pricing that's
changing all the time I never thought of
that for my business so an example of
um what we do as humans when we bring
brainstorm we would um if we want to
generate ideas this is well known like
um Robert sapolsky writes a great book
about
um the brain and Neuroscience he's a
he's a terrific Professor here called
behave highly recommended if you want to
spend a lot of time reading a book about
Neuroscience it's really in detail but
he talks about how our brain works so
we're mimicking what happens to your
brain if I give you an analog and I say
you know hey
um you know uh think of uh you know
think of a great way to deliver dinner
to the dinner table tonight you might
come up with ideas and they say okay
well now let's do dinner
um like a um
like a um a snow cone counter at a at a
fair would do it
suddenly you think of you you just you
bring up all the ideas about snow cones
and county fairs and you sort of apply
that to this idea of creating dinners
tonight for your family that's what what
happens in our head is we pull up all of
this information related to whatever
experiences we've had
and we put them together with our idea
and we generate new ideas that's not
that's an idea Generation generation
technique I've written about it done
we've there's many many studies about it
it's proven to generate new and novel
ideas the only limitation is it's
limited to the knowledge I have about
that analog what was fascinating about
this was the computer is Relentless it
can keep going this this student could
just put in more and more Clash this go
to market business strategy from this
company with my idea oh let's just do
another let's do another let's do
another and it generated all kinds of
new ideas and the student was driving it
it was it was the exercise of creativity
was coming up with these prompts and
then sifting through the results and it
was uh fascinating
um to see the the lights turn on and see
new directions get created so a lot of
you are asking how might this work in my
field how might this work in the field I
think this is a really interesting
prompting technique that is an example
of leveraging sort of a very very
um big big large data set that might
have information I I'm not going to even
have in my head but I have enough of an
inquiry I could inquire about it and
sort of put it together
um with that let's jump to that let's
run through these quickly and then then
get to q a this was another one and I
want to credit
um Ben Johnstone
um from UTS Sydney who's a collaborator
that helped us with this one
um he's going to use this in his class
in the summer we
um we used a um
uh a custom-built AI that that just
basically was a plug-in to chat GPT to
do this following assignment which
traditionally was an assignment I'll
just explain it to you we have students
work in this worksheet and they they use
different story
um structures to tell the story of their
company so this is helpful with you know
writing copy for a website this is
helpful to communicate your idea to an
investor
um it would it would say things like
write about your company as if it's a
haiku write about your your company as
if it's a review on Amazon
your company as if it's a um a New York
Times
um obituary about you as the founder so
it's just it's different ways to to get
the
the founder the student Founders to
think about their their um organization
their company their message in different
ways so a lot of you are asking like hey
what you know how could I use this in um
creative I'm running an advertising
agent somebody asked about that this is
a really good example of that it's like
hey these you do this all the time
you're you're being creative you're
trying different story molds you're
you're doing different things
and then we would evaluate that work in
class people would bring it in we'd put
Post-its on things that were new and
different and on we'd have a discussion
and generally students got a lot out of
it so we thought huh this is a really
powerful technique what if we had
um the AI generate a lot more material
so
what we did was we built a um a slack
Channel and used this and we basically
had students write a a couple of short
paragraphs about their
um their company and their idea
and um chat GPT generated all kinds of
material like it generated two or three
or four times the amount of material
they'd ever been assigned to do
so their job became editing it so what
they ended up with was the the
effectively the assignment now was
editing a mountain of material generated
by
um uh Chach EBT
and sifting through it and seeing what
was new to them and new and potentially
worthy of inquiry in green what this is
the powerful thing and they also got
things they marked and read which were
things they they felt were entirely not
something that they wanted to use in
their company which was a new part of
the assignment we'd never think about it
when they did the assignment themselves
they never did things they didn't want
to share they only did things they did
want to share now we had all this
material so the conversation was quite
different than in the past
um
you know they they now have material we
could talk about why don't you like that
which we never had that conversation
before why do you like it and it wasn't
generated by them and then after that
discussion we had them you know spend 20
or 30 minutes and build out sort of a
final version by themselves
and this is the fascinating thing that
Sebastian's you know gonna figure out
how we researched was
um none of the students used anything
generated
um from chat gbt they were averted back
to
um previous material it was it was
interesting and we had a discussion with
that with the students afterwards
um and
um I don't know your takeaway is
Sebastian but this is this fascinating
thing of they admitted there was new
material but they they weren't quite
able to process it and use it and our
hypothesis was when we did this which
was they were going to be far more open
to using stuff that came from an
objective Source a computer and perhaps
incorporate it faster than they did
input from other humans so we're still
baffled on that one so um anybody who's
a psychologist out there that uh chime
in and put something in the Q a please
do
um but that was that's the first time in
continuing to sort of
work with tools like that and ask
um go back and ask students what was
your experience with that when now we go
back and look at the end one when we
look back at some of your edits and some
things you like what was your decision
not to go forward and learning and this
this sort of drives you know my thinking
as an as somebody running the classroom
a lot and for Sebastian thinking about
how might that be an area for a research
effort
and then this last one
um noticing patterns with AI this isn't
so we do a lot of um testing and
interviewing as we're putting products
out in the marketplace in this effort um
and what we did was started to have
students students had routinely been
doing asking permission as they test a
product or service you know to somebody
would it be okay if I recorded this
interview so I have a record of it and
can review it later so it's just we do
that hygiene if somebody's okay with
that it gets reported we take their
names out you know there's we're careful
about personal information but they
begin to do it something really
effective which we teach in design
process is continue to ask consistent
questions so if if I'm let's say I'm
this student I have
um somebody looking to lease an office
space look at my website and I'm giving
the example of that student that we
talked about in the cross domain
prompting
you know somebody will take a look at
the website and then they'll say okay
you know tell me what you think of the
product and I'll ask that question
consistent with each one you know would
you use it yes or no either answer or he
asked why I mean he's very very
consistent about that and the cool thing
is then what what we have is we have a
we have a record of those interviews and
very easy to compare because he's asking
consistent questions
okay we also have a mountain of material
there's a there's a lot of interviews
happening there's a lot of these
questions and you know three iterations
I have this iteration then this
iteration I want to compare the results
because these two different folks now
you know and students are doing this you
know one with their own sort of reaction
to the interview and then also reading
the transcripts and highlighting you
know what are areas where you know my
customer my potential customers are
expressing anxiety
um where is the need more clearly
expressed you know they're doing all
that kind of work and we've been doing
that for a long time too much to to
success it was it's terrific
and now what we had was we had a few of
the um a few of these students group
also run through something called
sentiment analysis which you you'd load
the the copy again we've cleaned out the
names there's no no personal information
and just ask the sentiment analysis
where do you notice anxiety where do you
notice express pain you know
um where is somebody the most tense
where are they most in engaged and a lot
of times it's I mean we've we could
share these these screens that can it's
not that smart so it'll Miss it'll miss
things like sarcasm right it doesn't get
sarcasm
um so a lot of that stuff was really
really helpful but was fascinating was
being able to score interviews across
different demographics so we had a
different team working on making a
decision with this really cool
Rehabilitation device they have a really
interesting take on
um real Rehabilitation we have an injury
that affects your walking so this is
something that they've been working on
and they didn't know whether they wanted
to focus on people older patients with
you know broken hips and neuropathy and
things like that or or people with knee
injuries or hip injuries regardless of
age and they were just analyzing it and
um they used they would talk as two
Founders back and forth and review the
content it was very helpful for them to
see the sentiment analysis and see some
areas where there was far more
nervousness about the situation than not
and they ended up finding that hey with
some of the um
the older people there was far more
expressed anxiety and it was great
because they felt that from the
interviews and they felt it from reading
but it was very they noted it was very
helpful for them to to sort of have a
third party review it and see that and
the sentiment analysis would literally
pull out the
um the areas of the interview that that
it felt that the computer saw anxiety
and they were able to compare
um their own notes so the idea was do it
yourself and now you've got this in a
way a third party review but the cool
thing is the third party review think
about it could go through all of their
interviews it was you know an insane
amount of effort for them to review all
of it in the past as opposed to have
something go through and have them sort
of go back through their reasoning so a
different way of using it and
um this is an example of something I
sort of felt and fashion maybe the same
is it was it had a multiplying effect to
their creative effort it was a really
good tool not to use and just take the
answer but use it as an inquiry device
meaning go back into just a few of the
interviews that it's said had much more
anxiety and go through and look at those
sentences and see if they felt the same
about it and they had already marked it
or it was different or was it something
else going on
um just a great way to use their time
effectively with a large data set to to
redirect their their efforts to certain
areas
I think that's a great lead over to um I
see a lot of questions coming in
relating to um how do I prompt it how
can I use it as you were saying there
were a lot of questions relating to well
how can I use it for this use case that
how do I prompt it effectively so yeah
you want to share your screen and just
do a demo it'd be kind of fun absolutely
um I think before we go to
q a and live demo let's combine the two
um I just very quickly notes on prompt
engineering as promised this is the
basic way of prompting that most people
do so write a five paragraph essay use
it on using social media and business
and then people many would say well it's
generic it's bland it's not in my voice
you know most of those things would lead
to including my students and many others
thinking well this isn't useful this
isn't giving me anything
um so the next level of prompting would
be
um you guided a little more it needs
context this was your question Bonnie
you asked it this is important is your
question does go in but think of that as
a not a nefarious activity Bonnie was
asking a question like what happens when
I ask a question does that question go
in it's absolutely and be thoughtful
about what you want to share meaning the
example of these students were very cool
like don't share personal data don't
share something that's you know
proprietary about your technology or
working on something but but these
things you if you give it context that
does go in but it's super helpful and
this is where I I think the context in
all of the examples you know the the
there was some level of context you
needed you know that they they did in
advance
it doesn't know about you and your
context so then at the next level would
be that you actually use it to iterate
so you use it as a discussion partner
you need to give it some guidance and
help and then you would say well this
paragraph doesn't really work and expand
this one I need an example here so you
actually engage what I usually say in
class is you know low effort prompts
means low low quality output so we
actually need to help it along a little
bit and and give it an indication of
what you're looking for and then you can
leverage it you know much much better
get much much more useful output so I
think I hope that at least speaks to
some of the you know questions I've been
seeing here but what do you say Perry
should we do a demo uh yeah something
yeah yes of course
um
who knows what's going to happen with
the technology I have no idea awesome
but but let's see what happens let me
know if you if you don't see uh Chachi
PT and George your question how long is
do you think prompt engineering could be
relevant I think it'll shift and change
and we'll get better and better at it
but it's um that's if there's something
um powerful it's something we I I guess
Sebastian and I haven't talked about
this it's it's not a one-and-done thing
meaning I'm still finding techniques and
um and sort of looking at thinking about
my creative process the example the
analogs and cross-domain prompting was a
really interesting collaboration and
thinking about wow that's that's we had
to sort of work out how to do that
prompting and we see our students and us
getting better at it with iteration
um so that's that's something to think
about I I think it is your ability to
um leverage these
um tools is a function of your ability
it can't think of a good question it
can't think of a good context it's not
it's not capable so if you ask a really
interesting yeah it'll give you a
general answer but if you prompt it
correctly George I think this this is
the key is
um we've seen uh really interesting
results
yeah so uh exactly and I think the best
there's a lot of talk about you know
optimal problems and you know here are
some secret prompts magical prompts the
best thing is to Tinker and no but but
with that in mind I think these this way
of you know prompting it of giving it
context iterating uh and just learning
by by doing is is the best advice I've
seen at least out there
um what should we ask it for parity
um what do you think let me find so
there's a there's a bunch of
um folks asking about
different areas somebody was in an
advertising firm so let's let's maybe
think of like uh we don't we don't work
in an advertising firm but let's let's
uh let's maybe
um do an example of cross domain
prompting
okay so let's do help me come up with uh
marketing account and we just see the Q
a slide you need to share your next at
least that's what I see I see live view
um discussion q a slide still
all right for a a company uh that wants
to let's do something very
uh Basics wants to sell uh
new shoes
um yeah so here
sure I'd be happy to help
um so I wasn't very friendly I should
have said please probably yeah it seems
to work better that way uh but here's
the campaign overview uh it's a focus on
the perfect style blend of comfort style
and Innovation uh so it's it's I'd say
it's at least helping me hit the ground
running with this marketing campaign
right yeah now give it a little bit more
context so with the question like maybe
um we make special shoes
um that are made with a unique leather
from Italy in a unique style that mixes
you know uh fashion with everyday wear
so now we give it more context
and
um let's come up with a cross domain and
we want to figure out what what do we
want to figure out for them
um so we can
um so we can ask it to use Concepts from
um evolutionary biology yeah
allegi to Market
the unique design
okay so now let's pause before you I hit
enter anyway because it takes a minute
to get back but yeah so what so it
sounds like we're asking a goofy
question as the resident you know sort
of expert in creative process our goal
if we're actually trying to come up with
a breakthrough idea we should sort of
push for a variance of ideas there's
another talk you could look up or Robin
I think I've given this talk for this
group so
the idea of a distribution of ideas we
want to come up with a lot of ideas so
this is this is either you're going to
help us with that and we want to come up
with really wacky and out there ideas
because just the other side of wacky is
genius like there there's a high
correlation that we don't want to stay
in this Middle Ground so what's
interesting is the prompt is inspired by
especially that's an interesting prompt
you know right it's like oh that's not
obvious to me it's like I'm eager to see
what it comes up with
um and keep in mind it may be our
purpose is not to have the best ideas
the purpose is to have more ideas and
ideas that might provoke our thinking
and our thoughts if Sebastian are the
two people running this advertising firm
we want to help me with a client we want
a lot of really creative ideas well we
have to generate a mountain of ideas and
then as humans will edit them down so
what did it come up with
uh so here it's coming up with something
sounds pretty cool to me at least the
perfect union of Nature and
craftsmanship it's going to focus on
promoting them as a fusion of
evolutionary biology inspired design and
traditional Italian craftsmanship I I
think that's Innovative at least I don't
know if it makes much sense but well
because it's it's ideas and if nothing
else it provokes me and I react and I
say no that doesn't make sense maybe
this could make sense so even kind of
those negative defensive reactions can
serve a purpose and this isn't one and
done so you could say give them the same
prompt and say
um you know uh how might this uh or
apply the
um the concepts of a um Mass retailer to
this right and then we could we can just
come over the list of prompts I'm just
throwing out what's coming to mind
um but it's not one and done we're not
saying oh that didn't generate something
the purpose is not
um necessarily well with creative
process the purpose is never Quality
quality comes from quantity what what I
see in my work is this is an amazing uh
technology to help you generate
particularly when you're alone to help
you generate more quantity
and we all do not generate the perfect
ideas you know right off the bat and go
hmm I've got the perfect idea here it is
we the way that that we have seen
success and what we train all of these
Stanford students and here at the design
school is routinely being able to
generate a lot of material and then edit
down and go through it and the purposes
yeah sorry go ahead what you got
uh no I I just want to say here is uh I
mean I think my prompt didn't make much
sense but I mean again the AI doesn't
judge it just goes with it and and
generates new output
um I I noticed that time is flying and
and we're going to have time for a
proper wrap-up I I did see a question
someone was looking through my history
here which is fine I have nothing to
hide but uh someone saw that I I had
written a story in Swedish here about a
dragon so that was actually uh something
I did with my four-year-old daughter uh
so we do sometimes we do for a bedtime
story I ask it to write a good night
story for her and she prompts it and she
wants it to be a about a dragon a wolf
and in the desert and then they wrote
this story about how the dragon scenes
uh uh dangerous but it's actually nice
and it breathes fire on the sand so it
created this that beautiful landscape of
of crystals and glass and then what we
did was we took that prompt with us and
generated pictures of her with the
dragon and the Wolf so that's maybe not
classic use case but that's that's
something that we kind of share as a fun
activity and that is quite creative I
think
um right so yeah so we're at time that
flew by yeah we are I mean one thing I'd
say Sebastian is we we truly love this
kind of work it's like we're we're
sharing with you the questions we're
asking and again the core question we
keep asking is if if we could use this
as an as an as an area to inquire and
generate more options we feel that might
be very very helpful as a as sort of a
core way of thinking about
um leveraging this technology in
Creative work and that's what we
continue to work on and you'll you'll um
a few people ask for more research
papers so I'm sure Sebastian is eager to
get some some hits on those so so Google
him and you will find some really
interesting reads if you haven't read a
research paper get ready for something
that you need a big cup of coffee and
some patience to get through Sebastian
doesn't quite read like the the uh you
know article in um in you know a
newspaper or something but uh they're
awesome and it'll go into this area and
you know thanks for being here like we
love doing this thanks Robin uh Tim Amy
um you know for helping us do this but
just we're just an open Buck like this
is what we're working on
thank you so much Carrie thank you thank
you so much Sebastian you know we had so
many comments so many questions
the results of the poll the poll results
that we put up at the very beginning you
know how much experience do you had have
with
um generative AI tools we had 54 of
people that spent a little time 28 of
people who have never used it we had 17
to use it regularly and then we had 1.3
percent are experts so
um I I hope that I hope that who however
you're joining us today that you know
you heard something new from
um Perry and Sebastian or maybe if
you've never used it or you're brand new
you saw a use case and and that's in
something you took away from that that's
awesome
um this was brought to you by the
creativity and design thinking program
if you want to hear more from Perry
check out that program it's linked in
your dashboard in the upper right we
will be sending out a recording
um for this and we have recorded all
your comments and all your questions so
that when we are going to do another
live session we know exactly where
people are and what they're asking and
where we can go next so everyone thank
you so much for joining us we really
appreciate it we'd love to keep these as
interactive as possible if we didn't get
to your question sorry about that like
literally hundreds of them coming in so
fast
which is which is awesome and great and
um we are signing off from Stanford to
wherever you are in the world thanks for
joining us today appreciate it